[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine and this week
we're talking about
finding the middle ground for aikido
what's all the middle missing material
in aikido so
in aikido we definitely know what the
techniques are and we definitely know
what the philosophy
or the ideas around the philosophy are
what's all that middle ground in the
middle of aikido
so this video series we're going to talk
about my approach to aikido and how i've
solved those problems for myself so
first you have to have a concrete
philosophy that you believe in so what's
your concrete philosophy that you
believe in
so so i have a set of six tenets that i
use to explain aikido
and and basically that all boils down to
a few things i believe the philosophy of
aikido is
that it's a martial art that enables you
to defend yourself
against uh bigger stronger people um in
a way that uh
you can have a joyful practice right so
meaning you can have an enjoyable
practice that you participate in all the
time
and that's available to all different
people
and that's you know comes from a lot of
smaller ideas thought out if you want to
check out what my my tenants of aikido
are i'll post a link below and you can
see what that is but
that's the basic philosophy that i
personally have for aikido and i think
that philosophy lines up with
what a lot of people would say their
philosophy of aikido is
so when we're looking at that we have to
identify what problems we're going to
have right
so i would i would love to just have
this philosophy and it's probably a lot
of people just love to have this
philosophy but what are you gonna do
when someone tries to interrupt that
philosophy right so i want to live a
peaceful life
and someone says you know i'm gonna
attack you what what do we do about that
so some of the key problems we have to
to outline and the problems will tell us
what our goals need to be
is one uh in aikido because the practice
is available to everyone meaning
everyone should be able to do this
practice
somehow we have to eliminate physicality
being a big part of what aikido is so
meaning
i'm going to accept the fact that i
can't be the biggest buffest strongest
dude ever right so i'm going to have to
accept a position where there's going to
be a lot of people who are bigger
stronger and faster and more skilled
than i am
and that's just going to be the way it
is right so this makes aikido available
to a lot more people it makes it
available to children
and old people and weak people and all
kinds of people that maybe can't take on
really robust
active practices and so because they
can't do that
their options are limited i believe
aikido is a system that should be
available to
anyone right so so that's part of it is
we have to face the fact that most of
the time
the person attacking us is going to be
bigger and stronger than us
now that's going to really kind of limit
us in a lot of ways because most martial
arts systems what their goal is
is to just become either the biggest
person or the fastest person
or the most skilled person right so
either i'm going to beat you with super
strength or conditioning some some kind
of
forceful power i have or i'm gonna beat
you because i'm really fast and i train
myself to be really fast
or i'm gonna beat you because i'm really
skilled i'm gonna get super skilled well
in aikido we're already saying that well
we're probably not gonna be
the the biggest strongest person the
fastest person or the most skilled
person
so how in the heck are we going to deal
with someone else right
so i believe aikido has a set of goals
that help us with this
right so one of the goals is we want to
be
ahead of someone else and this goal is
so simple that we forget about it all
the time
right so being ahead means a simple it
could be a simple thing like
um that looks like a dangerous place to
go i'm not going to go to that dangerous
place right
that doesn't sound like much of a thing
but being able to use that in a creative
way that sometimes can get you out of
really bad situations
is ideal right so one of the main goals
of aikido is just to be ahead of our
attackers and what our attackers know
and that could be in a in a short frame
right so meaning that
i know this guy's going to punch me in a
minute and i need to do something before
he punches me
or it could be in a big frame like i
don't want to live in that country
because it seems like a dangerous
country or i don't want to go to that
place
now we can't always meet that goal right
so sometimes you're going to have to go
places that are potentially dangerous
or deal with people that are going to be
potentially dangerous right so we have
to have tactics that enable us to deal
with this
but i believe aikido's first main goal
is simply to be ahead
right and so that's a way that we could
definitely deal with people who are
bigger and stronger and more skilled
than us
is to be ahead of them and i think the
founder of aikido
talked about this kind of stuff all the
time right one of the big things he said
was before someone attacks me
i see a little light come out from them
and i just move out of the way of the
light now that sounds kind of mysterious
and weird but i think what he was saying
was i understand what someone's intent
is
before they do it and so i just don't
i'm not there where they want to attack
me right and that's a real simple idea
to be ahead
the founder also said that he would give
a certificate of mastery of aikido to
anyone who could surprise him right
sneak up on him and surprise him
um that's another sign that um if you
could do that then apparently you're
more ahead than
the founder of aikido is so you've
already achieved a lot of ability
because he was a really ahead person
right so he really
knew what was going on before it
happened so being ahead is one of the
key goals in aikido and so and before we
need we can start thinking about the
techniques at all we got to think what's
one of the big goals one of the big
goals is to be ahead
so i believe aikido has three main goals
we're going to talk about those main
goal the other main goals
in the following videos i'm christopher
hine thanks for watching